javier está calibrando equipo médico de
diagnóstico por imágenes sofisticados el
manual reporta que la tangente de un
ángulo en particular es 1 digamos que es
la tangente de un ángulo particular que
es teta es igual a 1 que debería de
hacer javier para encontrar el ángulo
y te invito a pausar el vídeo ver estas
opciones y pensar cuál de estas opciones
debería de tomar para encontrar el
ángulo
así que analicemos cada una entonces la
primera bueno de hecho en vez de ver las
opciones pensemos en lo que haríamos
nosotros para encontrar el ángulo
tenemos que la tangente de un ángulo es
igual a 1
una de las cosas que quizá quieras hacer
es decir bueno si tomamos la tangente
inversa si tomamos la tangente inversa
de la tangente
de teta
así que si tomamos la tangente inversa
de ambos lados de la expresión
por supuesto tendríamos la tangente
inversa de la tangente de teta si el
dominio de aquí está restringido
apropiadamente
esto sería igual a teta así que podemos
decir que teta es igual a la tangente
inversa de 1 así que puede ser tentador
escoger esta de aquí teclear tangente
inversa de 1 a la calculadora tal vez
tal vez esta parece ser la mejor opción
pero recuerden que mencioné que se
tendría que restringir el dominio aquí
si restringimos los posibles valores de
t está aquí apropiadamente entonces esto
puede ser simplificado a esto pero hay
un caso en el que esto no pasa y ese es
cuando escogemos zetas fuera del rango
de la función tangente inversa y que es
lo que quiero decir con eso solo base
monos en la idea de que hay múltiples
ángulos cuya tangente es 1 y deja dibujo
eso con el círculo unitario
dibujar en el círculo unitario
y ese es mi eje x ese es mi eje g
deja dibujó mi círculo unitario aquí
de hecho tal vez ni siquiera tenemos que
dibujar el círculo unitario porque la
tangente está más relacionada con la
pendiente del rayo creado por el ángulo
en donde intersec a el círculo unitario
como sería el caso del seno y coseno así
que si tienes puedes tener este ángulo
de aquí digamos que este este está donde
la tangente de teta es la pendiente de
esta línea y este ángulo terminal
el rayo terminal podrías decir el ángulo
del otro lado el rayo inicial es el eje
x positivo y podrías decir que la
tangente de theta la tangente de teta es
1 porque la pendiente de esta línea es 1
déjalo escribo la tangente de teta es
igual a 1 pero puedo construir otro
theta cuya tangente sea igual a 1 yendo
por este camino y esencialmente estoy
yendo en dirección opuesta pero la
pendiente de esta línea
así que llamemos a este teta 2
a tan gente de teta 2 también va a ser
igual a 1 y por supuesto que puedes ir
abajo puedes ir otros pirra dianes y
volver al ángulo original pero
funcionalmente es el mismo ángulo en
términos de su posición relativa al eje
x positivo o en qué dirección está
señalando pero este es fundamentalmente
un ángulo diferente por lo que no
sabemos no tenemos suficiente
información
si solo sabemos lo que nos dice el
enunciado no tenemos suficiente
información para saber exactamente de
qué datos estamos hablando si estamos
hablando de este dato o de este dato así
que yo diría que la opción correcta es
obtener más información hay múltiples
ángulos que satisfacen esa descripción